[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique  ]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Oh
Houston, nous avons un problème, seules quelques
personnes réalisent ce que cela signifie d'avoir un
problème quand vous êtes dedans et fermé
et capsule comme un vaisseau spatial le
le problème est qu'il n'y a pas d'
alternative il n'y a rien au-delà et
donc où sur terre nous croyons ce qui va le
réparer oui et cela a un point de vue différent
il dit que nous et quelque chose va réparer nous avons
besoin de chance un autre vaisseau spatial
quelque chose parce que ce que nous avons maintenant
est  va être terminé comme une estimation
vous vous sentez exclu d'un groupe particulier
de personnes et ce sont les gens qui
ont la majorité ils sont vous n'étant pas
conscients du danger dans lequel ils vivent
mais maintenant supposons que je vais vous changer
tous  supposons que je puisse vous transférer l'
expérience que j'ai, alors
vous sortiriez et  voyez la terre et
vous verriez le ciel bleu pas le
ciel bleu que vous voyez quand vous êtes en dehors de
l'espace vous voyez que vous êtes le
seul avec la seule planète dont vous n'avez pas de
réserve et donc vous devez prendre soin de
cela  un sur notre planète, nous devons
conserver notre propre planète et vous quand vous
avez en fait l'esprit et l'intérieur
et l'attitude d'un national, vous commencez
à aimer la terre d'une manière que les autres ne
peuvent pas et si vous aimez vraiment quelque chose que
vous ne faites pas
je ne veux pas le perdre tu sais ma femme elle ne veut pas
me perdre elle veut tout faire
comme je reste en vie c'est l'amour et comme
il se doit
que l'humanité devrait arriver à la terre
nous nous les gens venant des mêmes
molécules  à partir d'une étoile sanglante étoile
qui l'éclate nous qui avons
développé pendant des milliards d'années la vie la
vie est faite par nous nous l'humanité sommes si
fortes que nous pouvons sauver la terre mais nous
ne pouvons pas non plus la détruire même une petite chose
fait quelque chose
[  Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[App  lause]